from a few hundred australian humpback
whales left today there are tens of
thousands after commercial whaling was
banned in the 1970s
it's good for business
whale watching season in full swing
again
these giants migrate from antarctica to
the top of australia and back again
a journey of more than 3 thousand miles
they've been on the surface peck
slapping
head rising tail lobbing incredible
it never loses as potent
it's it's an amazing experience
also amazing knowing them the way wally
franklin does
spending decades individually
identifying and photographing whales as
the population bounced back
it was
a remarkable experience to be able to
watch
as the eastern australian humpback
whales were covered
they're now almost back to 40 000 which
is where we believe they were before
whaling and that's just wonderful
but there's trouble ahead for the
humpbacks
the problem for these whales is global
warming water temperatures are rising
and the population of krill their main
food supply is falling so that means
that these whales are having to adapt
fast
with a bird's eye view scientists can
tell if they're losing weight
less food means less energy so these
whales aren't traveling to breed as far
north as they used to
what is the long-term fear with climate
change and its impact on the whales yeah
so we're worried that um the animals are
actually starting to starve so they're
getting less food supply and the
long-term effect could obviously be that
the number of whales are going down in
the future
but we don't know that yet
it was here
we should be somewhere nearby
even tiny flakes of whale skin
skimmed from the sea could hold answers
i think we're going to see drastic
changes in the next five to 10 years we
have a stabilization of the population
now and now the question is how will
these animals cope with climate change
how will they adapt to these changes in
the ocean
once almost lost these denizens of the
deep are back
but there is danger in an ever hotter
planet
nicole johnston
sky news
queensland